hello everyone I would like to welcome
you to today's webinar entitled using
genomics wearables and big data to
manage health and disease my name is
Annette Cruz and I am the program
manager of the Stanford genetics and
genomics certificate program at the
Stanford center for professional
development this webinar is brought to
you by the Stanford center for
professional development and the
Stanford genetics and genomics
certificate program take online courses
in genetics and genomics and gain a
greater understanding of biology human
health and personalized medicine tap
into the world-class research of
Stanford faculty and industry experts to
acquire the skills and knowledge you
need to succeed in the rapidly evolving
genetics industry visit genetic
certificates at stanford.edu to learn
more before we begin I would like to
introduce you to today's featured
presenter dr. Michael Schneider dr.
Schneider is a Stanford a Shulman
professor and chair of genetics and the
director of the center of genomics and
personalized medicine dr. Snyder
received PhD training at the California
Institute of Technology and carried out
postdoctoral training at Stanford
University he is a leader in the field
of functional genomics and proteomics
and one of the major participants of the
encode project his laboratory study was
the first to perform a large-scale
functional genomics project in an any
organism and has launched many
technologies in genomics and proteomics
that have been used for characterizing
genomes podiums and regulatory networks
I would like to turn it over to Mike now
great well thanks very much for having
me on this program I look forward to
telling you about some of the things
Rupp's are using data to help manage
people's health and ideally help manage
their and ideally cure their disease so
this is an area as many of you
appreciate is incredibly hot these days
and very topical and I think one of the
events that really launched this was
when Obama
we're going to have a major initiative
in precision medicine this was in his
inaugural address in January 2015 and he
pointed to the DNA helix as a way in
which we're going to be able to use
genomics and information to be able to
manage better manage people's health
well I would argue this goes well beyond
just genomics I think we're going to see
an explosion of all kinds of data that
will help manage people's health and
protect medicines they should use at a
level that's never been done before
now before we dive into this let me
first show you a little bit about what
frames are thinking which is that your
health if you will it's a it's a state
and most of the time we're healthy and
in a healthy state but there are times
in which we get disease and we become
unhealthy when you get a viral infection
or perhaps even other nastier diseases
and these states they're influenced by
many different things they're influenced
by your DNA your so called genome which
is a collection of all your DNA
molecules and also the various things
you're exposed to the so called expose
ohms that would be the food you eat
pathogens you might be exposed to
various life stressors exercise we all
know intuitively that these will
contribute to your health and I would
argue a goal of us collectively is to
try and understand in quantitative terms
exactly how people when they're born
with a certain DNA sequence when they're
exposed to different molecules what kind
of health outcome we might predict and I
think this will occur in some if you
will probably Sikh fashion some means in
which we would be able to predict
whether someone might be healthy or or
get disease and just as an example if
you're at risk for Parkinson's you
probably don't want to be a pesticide
worker because that makes you a higher
risk for getting Parkinson's so and
there are DNA variants at leats
Parkinson's so again I think this is
where we're only going ahead I do
believe we're in a world where assume
people will be getting the genome
sequence before they're born and that
actually makes it all the more important
we understand what kinds of them
exposures these are what kind of health
outcomes now I think many of you know
it's possible to sequence people's DNA
so there's been a revolution in DNA
sequencing technology and it's at the
point where we can now sequence
someone's DNA for less than $2,000
although to interpret that TNA sequence
costs a lot more in fact it can cost as
much as fifteen or twenty thousand
dollars but that's not the only
revolution of technology that's
occurring there's other revolutions and
advanced technologies but mass
spectrometry the the sort of instruments
that you see in airports there's very
advanced instruments that let us measure
tens of thousands of molecules inside of
us that will indent at a level that's
never been done before so we can make
measurements of unprecedented scale and
be able to better define what people's
biochemical states are so a number of
years ago we launched a very large
project which we call personal omics
profiling where the idea is to make very
detailed measurements of people so we
make literally billions of measurements
of people every time we sample them so
we see we analyze their DNA that's their
genome to mention before well we also
analyze all these other features as well
so something called the epigenome which
is your modified DNA which we know is
influenced by the environment and all
those other things I mentioned earlier
we also measure all your RNA molecules
this was called your transcriptome all
your protein sets of proteome
special set of proteins called cytokines
they modulate your immune system and we
follow all your metabolites and small
molecules as well there are as many as
we can measure we follow your antibody
responses you may have heard about this
new area called microbiome this is an
area where we actually have many many
cells to live in and honest that really
microbes are actually been very
beneficial for our health a digester
foods we study that as well so we
actually measure mostly as we measure
out of blood but some we measure out
urine in the microbiome we
to measure leaving out of your stool
sample between these measurements of all
these different things again billions of
measurements every time we sample people
and the idea is that should have sample
people over time to see what keeps them
healthy and what makes them what feels
wrong when they get sick and we do
standard medical tests over here as well
we also have questionnaires and I'm
going to get back to these wearable
sensors at the end of the talk today so
basically why are we doing all this well
we're trying to understand why people
are healthy what keeps them healthy and
by understanding the biochemical
measures of health we also want to
happens when they do get sick and when
you do get a disease what what kinds of
biochemical events change during that
time and then how can we better manage
that
we won't understand how these different
dimension homes so the the proteome is
your collection of proteins and the
metabolize your collection of
metabolites and your microbiome is your
collection of microbes we won't
understand how they relate to one
another we know intuitively that the
food you eat in combination with your
genome and your biochemical marks on
your DNA somehow affects your your
health but we don't really understand
how those rules work and we'd like to
understand how they work so that we be
able to better manage your health that
is a site the certain foods can make you
better by eating them and they will be
specific for some individuals we'd like
people to eat those foods and hot foods
to make you unhealthy and they this can
be very personalized we're also trying
to understand how people react similarly
and how they react differently when
you're faced with say adverse conditions
if I you have a virus that comes along
most people respond somewhat similarly
in the sense of don't mount an immune
response but will be personal aspects of
this as well some people will make
certain cytokines and be able to better
fend off that virus and others not so
good and we'd like to understand why
that's the case
and perhaps most importantly that one
major reason we're doing this project is
we're trying to identify
actors that can basically help help
manage the health of an individual we to
learn things about people that we hope
will keep them healthy and you'll see
evidence of that as we go along so
basically many of you may know this
already but we actually started this
project by studying meat looks like we
lost some information here but basically
we've been profiling me for now over six
and a half years meaning we've taken
over 200 samples from 200 time points
from the many samples each time point
and during this time I've been through
ten viral infections they've also had
Lyme disease and we basically have as
they've been analyzing me and following
me very closely over this period and we
did this because we want to see again
what happens when I'm healthy and what
goes wrong when I get sick so every one
of these boxes is a viral infection it's
supposed to be a timeline here that
somehow got lost but basically during
every one of these viral infections I
have gotten six and we take many many
samples so for example during these are
all common colds I've had this was a
rhinovirus HIV this respiratory
syncytial virus that's a common cold in
kids and the virus is another one and so
we do dense sampling when I get a viral
infection and then we took the grade
give blood every two to three months
when I'm healthy and lately I've been
trying to invite Jerry supplements so
we've been sampling a lot
each of these is add a number into these
numbers and so again we're following
what happens as I go through these
various changes and first thing we did
was actually sequence my DNA I'll go
through this somewhat quickly because
I'd like to talk about two new exciting
stuff but from from my DNA sequence we
could predict my risk for many different
diseases and most of this I knew from my
family history or what I knew about
myself already meaning I was at low risk
for obesity nobody my family's ever been
overweight it was a high risk for
let's close this lipedema and high
cholesterol that shows up here as high
triglycerides there's a high risk for
those I knew that already because I knew
my cholesterol was high and I do take
statins to manage a high risk for
coronary artery disease that was known
as well now one of the big surprises for
my genome fellows has high risk for type
2 diabetes basically I went from having
a 27 percent chance of having this in my
lifetime so 46 percent chance so huge
increase and we actually were following
my glucose which is what happens when
you get diabetes your glucose goes off
and then in fact that did happen to me
during the course of the study my
glucose had been marching along just
fine and then it actually turns out
right after this nasty respiratory
syncytial virus infection my glucose
went quite off it got very high to the
point where in fact classified as
diabetic so when we first measured it
was on its way up at 127 a week later is
even higher this is a better measure for
steady-state glucose called a hemoglobin
a1c it was right on the edge it's Harvey
tree but div' leg meats is classified at
six point five hemoglobin a1c at six
point four it's right on the edge and
then five weeks later we measured me
again and sure enough I was actually
diabetic I had crossed the threshold out
of six point seven and that was over
five years ago that was april 11th 2011
because up until then I had the world's
first ayat I hate sweets because I
didn't know I had a problem I cut all
that out and just doubled my bike
instead of running and took about eight
months but I brought it down and the
control I got my glucose back together
so the this made a big splash at the
time because it's the first time someone
used their genome to predict their risk
for disease and it might be said got the
disease and in my case it was also
manageable and I was able to bring it
under control at least initially it was
also quite intriguing because it if you
notice when it occurred it occurred
right
after this nasty respiratory syncytial
virus infection so what we think is that
genetically predisposed for type 2
diabetes and then in conjunction with
this Nancy viral infection or or its
associated stretch response that's
what's triggered the disease now you may
think that this all has a happy ending
and it's not completely so it turns out
that we some people in fact criticize
and say maybe Mike that would have gone
away on its own you don't know that well
we accidentally did the right control
experiment so to speak that is to say we
kept profiling me but we're doing so
blindly as actually when we scaled
you'll see in a minute so that we now
follow a hundred people just like me
and when we scaled what we had stopped
looking at the data so we're here doing
this blindly and then at this point here
is somebody looked at my hemoglobin a1c
which turned out to be 7.0 it's a Mike
Geary 7.0 you're diabetic together so I
had no idea so he sampled me I stopped
running so I started running a nice and
bring it a little bit under control 25.7
but it it's these phases actually
drifted up in fact when I got Lyme
disease it hit six point five and it's
got a PI again recently so these days it
hovers between six point two and six
point four there's no question I have a
metabolic disorder and it's not fully
under control to them right on the verge
of being diabetic so again let's assume
you go over now into this new house and
I'm way elevated over what I should be
and it's not just me my brothers and
sisters all have elevated glucose we're
all fairly thin so it's a little bit
surprising but it's pretty clear then
that we have a genetic predisposition
for type two diabetes and that's what
this one is it's like to
so basically that again this is a chaste
virgin genomics and genetics had
predicted disease risk and might take
sex at least partially manage it I'll
probably be doing other things like
taking drugs actually definitely I'm in
control in the future now since that
time we've actually carried out many
other kinds of assays as well we didn't
do a whole image profiling we really
have if you will an IMAX movie type
picture of my biochemistry as it changes
during the time I get sick when I got
picture diabetes but we've actually been
making other measurements as well one
very fascinating area is the field of
epigenetics and epigenomic so
epigenomics is a collection of your
modifications to your chromosomes as you
will and one one important set of
modifications is those chemical
modifications called DNA methylation so
what's interesting is that we know that
your your DNA can get modified in
response to various environmental cues
but we don't fully understand this very
fascinating field but we know that this
one in particular modification of your
DNA by gaining map methylation which is
a chemical modification it actually we
know it's affected by nutrition it's
affected by things like exercise even
your age and other environmental cues
all affects your epigenetic programming
we also know that it's associated with
this modification with turning off your
genes so we don't fully understand how
this whole thing works but we do know
it's very very important and so the
things you do really do directly affect
your genes and your health and there are
now ways of mapping out all your
modified DNA sites and something called
the whole genome bisulfite sequencing
get full sophisticated I know but you
can actually map out all the
modifications in your DNA and their
millions of them using this technology
so we've done this for me and it's quite
fascinating you can see very interesting
regions of the gene
to change one area that we think is
interesting is trying to use your your
DNA modifications to predict what what
diseases you might be at risk for it
just like we use your genome sequencing
to predict what diseases you might catch
we can also look at your modified DNA to
try and do that as well to understand
what diseases you might be at risk for
and this is just one example I have a
number of regions in the genome like
this that are affected both genetically
and epigenetically so this is a case
where I've change in this particular
gene it's called the phosphodiesterase
team and the point out of all this is
that this gene turns out my father's
copy that's actually inactivated
genetically we all have these kinds of
mutations and then my case my father's
gene has actually been inactivated
through a genetic change and my mother's
copy is actually shut off by epigenetics
so the the the control sequences are
modified by this DNA methylation I
mentioned earlier but so we get very few
very little activity from the scene
which we can measure by certain readouts
is called RNA sequencing we get very few
RNAs that come from this so the point
out of all this is that might this gene
is inactivated to eight one
epigenetically and up one genetically
and as a consequence I actually have
this again inactivate about two methods
and in fact I make more eosinophils
which are involved in your immune
response I make more of these and I
normally should so we think that getting
your genome sequence is not only
important but we also would argue that
getting your epigenome determined as
well it's going to be just as important
possibly even more so because that's
something you might be able to modify
through the food you eating then you're
exercising such well as I mentioned
before we've actually scaled the snails
to study a hundred different people were
following a hundred people in incredible
detail just like me we sample them every
three months when they're healthy and if
something unfortunate happens like a
viral infection or stress responses
sample them more frequently we'll take
about five or so extra time points to
see what happens when people get sick we
also been running people through some of
these dietary perturbations these
dietary changes to see the effects of
diet on people's health and so again
we've been doing this in incredible
detail to see exactly what happens when
people take supplements or certain other
kinds of dietary changes and so we've
actually been doing this for now over
three years we've collected this where
we're at the beginning summer we've
collected over 1,500 cents time points
from people so we're really learning in
incredible detail how people are are
when they're healthy and what happens
when they do get sick and just give you
a few examples of some of the things we
learned from this change that we learned
important health information from almost
every single person we study so just to
give you some examples for the from the
genome sequence for the first hundred
people we've looked at 50 in detail and
three of them have mutations in their
DNA that are very very important for
them to know about so one individual had
a mutation in this gene which puts her a
high frequency or a high risk for this
type of cancer called paraganglioma
and because she had her sequined her
genome sequence she'll do it simple
you're in Texas keep an eye out for this
which she would not have done had we not
sequenced the DNA she would have no idea
that she was at risk for this another
individual has a protein C mutation
which puts in a high risk for
coagulation and the third person
actually has a mutation that affects
their heart rhythm
and possibility of heart attacks when we
call or heart failures something called
dilated cardiomyopathy so they have a
high risk for this which got discovered
partly through their family history and
partly because we see Spencer DNA and in
fact they do have some heart issues that
they're taking medication for so just
from their DNA alone for three people
turned out to be very very useful
information about things they should do
to keep an eye out for possible disease
risk and so again they will use this
information to better manage their
health it turns out we're also trying to
understand what happens in people when
they gain and lose weight so I think
many of you effective some of you may be
even experiencing this when people gain
too much weight and then if you lose it
again what does that mean biochemically
well we've looked at this in our group
of folks many of them I forgot to
mention but they're actually
pre-diabetic that there's a certain type
of pre-diabetes called insulin
resistance puts people at high risk for
type 2 diabetes most of these folks will
get type 2 diabetes so we've been
following them in in detail through the
same kind of profiling I mentioned and
as they say this group of 24 people went
through a weight gain weight loss study
and half of them are high risk for type
2 diabetes the other half are our normal
healthy folks and their match four for
their height and weight called body mass
index their match for that and so
basically we wanted to see what happens
to these folks when they gain and lose
weight and what we discovered first of
all even a baseline even before they
gain or lose weight we can tell the
pre-diabetics apart from the diabetics
based on their molecular composition so
this is by looking at all their RNA
molecules it turns out into resistant
folks are more elevated for certain
kinds of biochemical pathways like
oxidative phosphorylation that's a more
certain platelets specific genes that
are expressing some other diabetes
related genes are up in the
pre-diabetics relative to the insulin
sense of these are the healthy folks
some the same is true for metabolites I
showed you the the RNA but here's the
metabolites turns out the the insulin
resistant folks are pre-diabetic some
more likely have certain metabolites
elevated relatives of the sensitive
folks which will have other ones this is
just one example of a metabolite that's
actually it correlates very sharply with
their likelihood to get type 2 diabetes
and so what's interesting about this
metabolite is it actually comes from
your microbiome of all things
so the point out of all this is that
your molecular composition of people who
are at risk for type 2 diabetes and
those all right are very very different
what we found though is those people
gain and lose weight their biochemistry
does change or matically so these are
the molecules are through change every
row is a different molecule and every
column this is at the beginning this is
after they gain weight this is after
they lose weight so up here the
molecules will start out low and then
they get high when people gain weight
they go back to low and there are other
molecules that are high when they're
healthy and then when they gain weight
that she these molecules go down and
then they return to normal and their
other interesting ones that makes our
high go low but actually stay low they
don't quite come back and we can
actually fine identify these patterns
systematically and see the pathways to
change and the bottom line out of all
this is that when you gain weight
actually one interesting finding was
that your inflammation response goes up
so your immune response gets activated
when you gain weight and then it returns
to normal after you lose weight
another interesting pathway that changes
it turns out this one your hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy pathway that's what a lot
of mumbo-jumbo but what that means is
that this pathway gets activated which
puts you a very high risk for heart
attacks
when you gain weight and so we have a
biochemical understanding now how people
might get heart attacks when they gain
weight it comes from the fact that those
pathways activated when you gain weight
we've also found what turns out to be
really fascinating we found that even at
baseline even when people are healthy at
baseline
their profiles are very very different
so these are some very fascinating
immune molecules called cytokines it
turns out we all have different levels
of these cytokines even a baseline when
we're healthy so this is a complicated
figure but each color is a different
person and each name here around the
outside is the name of a cytokine this
is high levels and this is low levels
and what we found for example is that
the blue person has a lot of this one
il7 like brown person has AI p10 the
orange person is this one MIT 1b and so
on and so forth we all have different
levels of cytokine which probably puts
us at risk for certain diseases
differently so some of us if I were to
throw a virus on a room and half the
people like that six and half might not
and that might be because we have
different levels of cytokine that help
us spend off those diseases it also
turns out you've heard about your
microbiome perhaps your microbiome is
very very important it's it's the
collection of microbes in and on you
that and a lot of them are in your guy
and it's thought that we have ten times
as many bacteria in our gut as we do
human cells in our whole body and so the
microbiome is essential for digesting
your food and making essential vitamins
and things like this it's a very very
important good thing it's not always bad
like you might be worried about but it
turns out if we look at people's
microbiome that's everybody's microbiome
is different that was that's been known
for some time we all have different
might combine but some people can be
different in interesting ways this is
two people here who eat a lot of almonds
and they're very different this is a way
of relating people to one another in
this plot if you're similar you'll be
very close to each other these two
individuals eat a lot of almonds it's a
family a husband a wife they eat a lot
of almonds and they're just very
different from everyone else too tight
can really shape your microbiome and
long-term changes what we found is that
for short-term perturbations like the
weight gain study I mentioned or viral
infections you will shift
I am but you actually look closest to
yourself rather than someone else so
this is just comparing people they're
different time points every color is a
different person and it turns out that
people like this red person if we ask
who's closest to who well even if you
gain weight or have a viral infection
your microbiome will look closest to
yourself rather than someone else
so the point out of all this is we all
personal microbiomes that shifts when we
do gain weight or when we get a viral
infection and it's a short-term
perturbation it will ship but you'll
still look closest to you your bacteria
things are very personalized and that's
probably because we tend eat very
similar diets and our genome and
epigenome help control all this so this
is really where I think all this is
going I see a world where we'll be able
to understand where people when they're
faced with different perturbations so
some people if they eat unhealthy though
gain weight and become metabolically
amass other people if they eat unhealthy
they they actually may gain weight or
they may not but even if they gain
weight they can say metabolically
healthy there are plenty of very obese
people who don't have type 2 diabetes
and we'd like to understand
biochemically why that is so we can
better manage people but certainly we
can try and make sure that they eat
healthy foods but we should make sure
they eat healthy foods for them and then
this food can be very specific for
individuals we're also trying to
understand how certain people when they
get viral infections some get sick but
some others stay healthy and again we'd
like to try to keep people as healthy as
possible from these circumstances this
isn't the only study we're running we're
running another one where once a year
we're profiling people from around the
world actually as part of a meeting that
that I'm involved in it's called the
human per diem organization reaction are
part of this we had to go around and
sample people and follow their
biochemical composition we do this once
a year at the Haniel me
and so we'll be running around the world
taking a loquats of people to see how
biochemically different they are from
one another there's other projects out
there as well I've just listed a few
here so there's one in Seattle run by
Lee hood another than Sweden and so on
and so forth there's a number of
projects now erupting like those around
the world where people are trying to
understand but in biochemical detail how
you know what it means to be healthy and
what happens when people get sick
there's also a new exciting area that's
going to play into this in a big way and
this is using wearables and sensors to
be able to better manage people's health
so I mentioned all the biochemical
measurements well there's now getting to
be devices that lets you measure many
many different physiological sorts of
things in fact believe it or not there's
over 500 health-related devices on the
market that let you measure all kinds of
different things and I don't have time
to summarize them all but I'll tell you
about a few of these Sam the simple ones
or things like scales that you can stand
on that will actually measure your
weight and they will send that
information into your smart phone there
are continuous glucose monitors this is
especially useful for type 1 and type 2
diabetics these devices actually prick
on to you and they will continuously
measure your glucose probably the most
popular devices you're aware of these
smartwatches well over 50 available in
the market they measure all kinds of
interesting things they measure your
activities meaning steps running biking
they'll measure skin temperature they
can measure depends on the device but
they can measure your sleep stress
responses and so on they measure all
kinds of things and they're measuring
again in a continuous fashion and what's
important is that these devices collect
information and they repay that back
into your smartphone and what that means
is in the future your smartphone is
going to be your nexus of health
information all this information going
to relay back in to you
it's your smartphone and collect this
and to be honest I use eight of these
devices every day
to collect information it totals up to
about a two million data points per day
that you can collect and even if you
don't have time for all those devices
you can actually download free apps on
your iPhone and get some of these as
well so in fact this is one I use it's a
free app it lets you measure your step
sure you're biking you're running and
also tells you where you are
all at the same time so again this
information will all collect into your
iPhone and help manage us so so why is
this important well if you think about
it you probably go to a doctor at most
once a year if you're healthy and they
probably see you for about 15 minutes
maybe thirty minutes if you're lucky and
so out of the three hundred seventy
thousand waking human hits in a year the
doctor sees you for this just the
tiniest possible fraction of this like
that but the tiny drops in a very very
large bucket so we think there's value
to actually being able to measure people
all the time you'll collect a lot of
data and a lot of information about a
person over alarm period and not just in
that 15 minutes where you wonder if
that's representative of your health
state but by collecting this all the
time you really get a pretty good idea
of what your heart baseline heart rate
is and if it's changing the sort of
thing I can tell you personally oh
what's this going to mean is that in the
future your smartphone is really going
to be your command center your control
center for collecting all this
information that he called them leave
the biochemical information overhead in
here too and that will be able to help
you better manage your health to give
you a personal experience out of this
when I got Lyme disease last summer in
2015 and I my wearables were actually
incredibly valuable for discovering this
in fact as I discovered that my oxygen
level was lower than it was supposed to
be my heart rate was elevated and I knew
things weren't quite right and then I
got a low-grade fever for four days and
then the end I was able to figure out it
was Lyme disease I said
or way so it's a big deal but then on a
match line disease there and fact the
person recommended I get penicillin and
I told them I think I need doxycycline
and if I hadn't had the wear of first of
all the wearables help me find this in
the first place and thereby taking - man
- my my situation is actually get the
right able to get the right drug so I
think that's going to be one of many
examples in the future where these
wearables will feedback directly to you
and then you use let me go to the doctor
to help better manage your health and so
again well not only have about technical
measurements will have all these
physiological measurements as well so
this one Mike Snider's to try envision a
world where people will be getting their
genome sequence before they're born in
addition to all these biochemical
measures we're going to have wearable
information as well that all feeds back
again ideally it would feed back the
real-time or at least in short time and
with this we'll be able to better
predict disease risk catch disease early
monitor disease and treat it all based
on all this information the so-called
big data and the nice part about it is I
hope in the future we'll be shifting
medicine from being a reactive situation
where we react when people get sick
to proactive where we work to keep
people healthy that's really the goal
and so again here's where we're at
personal genome sequencing is here all
these other motio mcc's profiling is
really important I think these
longitudinal profiles are very very
valuable everyone is unique and so
everyone's special not just to the
mother they're very um have different
biochemical profile and they think we
all are going to be responsible for our
own health so that's wrapping it up I'm
going to turn it back over to Annette
and yeah and happy to take questions or
people have any but I have a wonderful
lab and wonderful collaborators these
all the people who helped out in this
study so that's you and that great
thanks Mike so before we do some quick
questions I'd like to tell you a little
bit about our program in our Center so
the Stanford center for professional
development makes it possible for
today's bus
brightest professionals to enroll in
Stanford University courses and programs
while they maintain their careers
curriculum some stanford departments is
delivered online at Stanford at company
work sites and international locations
providing a global community of learners
with flexibility and convenience and
enabling them to apply their education
to their work
additionally the Stanford center for
professional development has a long
history of extending the world-class
teaching and research of Stanford
faculty to industry corporations of all
sizes from startups to mature successful
enterprises visit SCPD Stanford etu to
learn more so now we have a few
questions so Mike when this become
available to everyone well right now
it's a research project so the way we
carries out it really is just for a
limited number of people the 100 folks
were following an incredible detail but
I think some form of this will come out
in the future obviously the wearables
are there now I think we're gonna see
there's starting to be some companies
forming in this area about measuring a
lot more data to be able to manage
people's health
so I'm guessing so some levels rolling
out now it's not covered in a typical
doctor's appointment but it wouldn't
surprise me if in five to ten years
we'll see a lot of this activity
certainly by ten years I think we'll see
a lot it won't be quite as steep as what
we're doing on me and these hundred
people but I think it will still have a
lot of data to be able to better manage
people's health and they didn't mention
but imaging data some of these other
things are going to be very very
important as well great
so with that thought is there such a
thing as too much information well from
my standpoint the answer's no now some
people may be overwhelmed by this but I
think you can manage the kind of
information that you want to come to you
so yes it's billions of data points but
in the end it always fills in to a few
common themes like you're either your
secretary or healthier have a viral
infection or maybe of Lyme disease so it
won't be like they'll get flooded with
billions of data points you'll get
filled with possible thing
that you should be on the alert for and
some people though they won't want this
information you don't want to wake up
every morning and worry oh I'm gonna get
Lyme disease or I'm going to get cancer
that would not be a very healthy
situation so if you're worried if you're
worried err and you're worried about
those stuff
my recommendation would be that you just
limit the information that comes back to
you only it would pop up if it seems a
very strong likelihood that this will
happen or there's certain simple tests
you should be doing so I think that
threshold what information you want to
come back to you will differ for
different people and again where you
should probably get less information
people who can handle lots of
information well by all means let them
have whatever they can handle yeah great
so I mean with all the information and
all the different devices and all of
these different collection of data what
about the privacy who owns all of this
information yeah what's the end of the
day I think you're the owner of your own
information in my opinion now you do
have to be coached it helps us in the
sense that we do have genetic counselors
involved to sort of let people know that
they may learn things you don't want to
hear about and such so we we do want to
manage that but as far as privacy in
terms of insurance companies and things
at least in the u.s. you're not allowed
to be discriminated for for employment
or health information although you can
for long-term disability and for life
insurance of those so you can be
discriminated again so that that is a
possible concern I would so argue it's
better to be know the information and
stay healthy and possibly pay a little
more for life insurance if you have to
that would be better than the
alternative which is to be unhealthy and
not know so it is a trade-off
unfortunately be nice obviously if there
wasn't any discrimination on those
things but yeah it's somewhat limited I
haven't heard any strong cases of
insurance companies discriminating or
people discriminating against
based on their genetic information
although it is you know conceivable it
could happen in the future but yeah I
think again if number-one priority would
be to stay healthy and I think the
information can help you do that I think
for privacy we should try and manage it
as best we 10 these days I don't think
you could ever say anything is
completely secure so even if you thought
you were storing it in a very very safe
place as a distinct chance it will get
hacked and somebody may have access to
it and that's why we'd like to avoid any
discrimination based on the sort of
information yeah thanks it's very
informative and I think everyone can
really take from this from this talk so
thank you
so again if you like this topic and
you're interested in more information
this webinars presented by the Stanford
genetics and genomics certificate
program visit genetic certificate
stanford.edu for more information thank
you everyone for listening bye